i wonder if i if i even have my arms
fully around exactly what's going on but
you know so again from my background as
a person who's a biologist fundamentally
looking at whole system biology meanings
at least at this whole cell level um is
is where a lot of my research was done
i understand intimately the role of
energy and resources and you know you
either
remembered to plate your cells out with
appropriate levels of medium and glucose
or you didn't you know and if you didn't
they would all ball up and get very
simple and very unhappy looking and and
i understand
where we are as a species
in this story and so that's a frame i
bring to this and i'm open to all the
other ones too but my frame says
we're at a really critical moment in our
species history
i think people are detecting that on
many different levels but of course you
can't even open up the newspaper or
online news source without finding out
there's something not quite right with
microplastics and where'd the fish go
and what's up with the insects and
can we really suck this aquifer down at
six percent a year when it takes ten
thousand years to recharge and on and on
and on right and and from that kovad
then becomes the backdrop which says
look we couldn't even discuss ivermectin
without like losing the plot line how
are we going to manage disappearing um
ecosystem services that we haven't even
properly mapped yet let alone begun to
appreciate this this is such a beautiful
point right if you are going to be
bewildered by a campaign as transparent
as the i don't know the great horse
dewormer
gunshot victim yes debacle if you're
going to be fooled by that you know
you're not going to get the question of
pesticides and its implication right
you're not going to be able to navigate
the question of how does
um you know a mrna
lipid nano particle vaccine compare to a
live attenuated virus you know
you just don't have the tools right
you're easily fooled and it's one thing
to know that and to say hey look
i'm out it's another thing to think you
do get it and
we've been
i don't know we've been
quite buffeted by many many people who
pretended to have good tools and just
just didn't
but i want to switch us switch gears a
little bit here and we have been so far
talking kind of generally about
where we're going you said you don't
you're not you don't quite have your
arms around where we are and i would say
actually i think that this is sort of
uh
the primary entrance requirement to the
adult discussion
right if you're really paying attention
to what's going on
you you know that you don't know where
we are right there are possibilities you
may have a sense that it's this and not
that you can say certain things aren't
likely to be true
but i don't know anybody right the most
informed people in the world who are not
on the inside
don't know what this is about and
therefore don't know
what it is that will be
protected and obscured in this phase
where we go from
the public health narrative collapsing
on the public health authorities to
whatever they're going to do in the
great scramble to come
and i fear
that because people have the sort of
sense of relief that you know i mean i
don't know what you've seen uh you're
you're out east you're in uh
massachusetts is that right
um so i'm out here in oregon we're
living physically very different uh
existences among
people who aren't connected
what i'm watching is
omicron
completely overwhelmed
even the false impression that control
was possible
and
it
caused everybody to kind of surrender
and they just stopped taking covet
seriously
and that was interesting and frankly
with omicron
it's probably the right approach for
many reasons because a you're not going
to control it with masks right you're
not going to control it with masks
boosters make less than no sense given
the evidence of
the vaccinated being so very vulnerable
to
contracting and transmitting omicron
but in any case people just sort of
i think they breathed a sigh of relief
and moved on and the problem is
we are dealing with
a
self-inflicted wound
kovid appears to be a self-inflicted
wound of
unprecedented scale
right two years of turning the entire
world upside down
over
a virus that appears to have been
enhanced
and then escaped
now that is an amazing
error to have made and the costs will
never be fully understood
right the costs are absolutely
gigantic so it stands to reason
that our top priority ought to be
figuring out
exactly what happened
and building the best protections we can
to make sure nothing like this ever
happens again because frankly as
bad and unprecedented as it was it could
have been worse so
then we are left with the question of
what should happen now and
my
increasingly i am preoccupied
with the way that those who did this are
going to escape being
properly
revealed
and the reforms that are necessary will
be avoided because of course this was
whatever its fundamental nature
this was
um the mother of all opportunities for
certain people right the amount of
wealth that was generated on the back of
kovid the amount of power that was
concentrated the amount of progress that
uh tyrants have made in getting us to
surrender our rights and getting used to
the idea that that's a normal thing to
do
right these were spectacular changes and
they are now going to do everything in
their power
to avoid us understanding what happened
so that they can do it again and
we must stop that but that involves
recognizing where we are this is not the
end it might be the end of covid it
might be that another variant pops up
and returns us to some place or takes us
someplace
new those are live possibilities you can
tell me if you see
reasons to think they aren't
but at the level of what happens to
society which frankly
i think you'll agree is much more
dangerous than what happens to us as a
result of this particular virus
we are still
in grave jeopardy and the game is only
just beginning
thank you i love having this
conversation i've been
so
um
it was may of 2020 when i put out a
first video i was like this thing kind
of looks like it came from a lab right
and i i was using the genetic
information on it in particular the pra
fur and cleavage site i was like that's
that's weird and i couldn't find any
other nearby viruses that had that
particular sequence you know so it had
to have gotten it from somewhere and so
there wasn't a a molecular or biological
or evolutionary
explanation for it that made sense so
you weigh the evidence and i was like
pretty sure this came from a lab right
so i was a conspiracy theorist for a
full year in the press and then somehow
that story changed one day and all of a
sudden it was okay to talk about it and
that was interesting watching the
narrative control but i agree with you
completely that
if we don't not only find out how it
arose and how it got to escape
not only find the people who were
responsible for that find out if they
broke any laws or rules right if we
don't do that
they've just learned oh we can get away
with this and when people have no
consequences and they learn they can get
away with something they'll do it again
particularly if they get to make
trillions of dollars and you know secure
vast new rights and powers and things
like that so
i think it's really troubling that my
culture in the united states that our
press is yeah they sort of weekly sort
of look at this lab leak thing but
they're not really on it it's like they
don't have an interest in finding out
why or how that might have happened and
i think that's an error a big error
because it'll just happen again that's
not that's not a that's that's about
that's not a prediction in the sense
that i'm trying to tell you something in
the future that's uncertain that's like
saying if i let go of a hammer it's
going to fall to the ground i don't
think it's an error
and i don't want to describe it in
overly deliberate terms because i think
a lot of this functions
subconsciously that people detect that
there is something desired from them and
they do it and it rewards them and they
don't exactly know why why they were
invited to do it but
the the whole idea
that
the you know the horses are out of the
barn
why are we so concerned with the origin
yes it's kind of interesting it would be
nice if we knew someday what happened
but
why does it change this is
very wrong on two fronts
i mean for one thing
if it did come from a lab and it seems
almost certain that it did
we have a right to know the protocols
that generated it which might well tell
us something useful about how to address
it and
the idea that anybody has the right to
say
no
you won't find anything interesting
there is
preposterous but what i really think is
happening is that a lot of people who
weren't ahead and who didn't suffer the
stigma of
saying hey
this looks like a lab leak it's not
making me happy to say it but it looks
like one
people who didn't do that and people who
said terrible things about folks like us
who did are
signaling to power
that effectively they're advertising a
willingness to embrace amnesty for the
lab league all right i'm not going to go
after this and the point is i see a
negotiation unfolding in the world at
the moment and the negotiation involves
people
you know
the public is going to want an
explanation of how the public health
authorities got it so wrong
and so there's a scramble
to fill that need but the point is the
people who got this so wrong are
connected to the most powerful forces in
the world
and so they get some say in who they
have to confess to and how much they
have to confess and what they want to do
is confess enough that it is satisfying
and not so much that anything changes
and i i really think this is what
happens next right they are bargaining
with the middle ground those who got it
wrong are going to move in the direction
of right but the whole idea is to save
the
elite rent seekers who at the very least
took merciless advantage of the
situation
from the reckoning that would be natural
and from the reforms that would plug the
leak
so
yeah i
the lab leak is a good model because we
won that battle for the most part early
and we can say what happened right there
was a mad scramble amongst people who
had gotten lab leak wrong to become the
new voices of reason who acknowledged
that there was a lab leak and were able
to point to indications that they may
have left that possibility open before
but anything was better than going to
the people who said actually you have no
idea how high the chances are and how
much the evidence there is and the fact
that there is exactly zero evidence
pointing in the other direction
and you know you ought to be thinking
about this
so yeah i i i see a kind of de facto
negotiation and i wish there was some
way to describe it so that people did
not hear it as the allegation of a
smoke-filled room in which people are
actually talking because that's not the
kind of negotiation it is
right it's an as-if negotiation
you know there's um
i agree with that i agree with that
there's
so there was a a
a chart in a book that showed um and
this was by ralph barrick and and it
showed this is pretty covet but it
showed
all the things that we we humans have
been doing with
corona viruses and so the first time
that we'd taken a chimera and taken a
piece off of one and put it in and made
it more effective in an animal model was
1998
and
there might have been earlier stuff but
that's the first publication on this
chart and then there's like all these
seminal things people are doing
including by 2002 ralph barrack had
figured out how to do the noseem insert
so that you could actually build an
entire viral construct without anybody
being able to detect that it had been
through a lab he got a patent on that it
was 2003 when sars broke out so prior to
to sars we
never had a pandemic coronavirus
prior to humans monkeying around trying
to make them more infectious we'd never
had one so i might my questioning about
this whole thing goes back a long way
now um
and
so you then you watch the mers thing
come out and you watch this thing come
out uh sarsko v2
it's clearly been manipulated and i you
know i have a whole story about omicron
too which looks even more manipulated is
pretty obvious so i think we have to
have that conversation though because
i don't know that we
it's pretty clear that whether people
meant well they had a white hat sort of
a reason they thought that this was
going to advance knowledge so that we
could learn things that would be
important i think what's missing in that
is the hubris
is has overshadowed this idea that even
30 000 tiny strings of letters which
we'll call the rna code of this
particular virus is too complicated for
us to understand or manage like it just
did wildly complex things inside the
human body when it got in there i don't
know if you saw this breath but there
was a study that showed that not only is
this 38 you know kilo bits of
information
come forward and enter a cell and do all
this stuff but it has little proteins
that it shuttles into the nucleus to
turn certain genes on and off it's just
so ridiculously complex but there are
people who think we can control that and
learn from that and and fiddle with that
um so in essence what we're dealing with
with stars cov2 now is humans as a
species were having to adjust to
a virus that didn't go through the
normal
call it normal
pathways so it's got a big sudden jump
in evolution
and that's not a normal condition so
we're going to we're going to learn some
things about this and i don't think
we're over
yet in just in learning some things
there might be things we discover in
three four five years like real
long-haul coveted we don't know we we
we don't know and that's what bothers me
is that these people who did this brett
they they still are operating with that
sort of hubris and impunity that says
well even if it escaped we can do better
next time but i don't
i think we're jeff goldblum's character
in jurassic park you know yeah or the
fly it's like just because you can
just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should so this is uh
this is a battle
that
i'm going to avoid ranting but this is a
battle that um
has been going on forever and that
animated me when i was a graduate
student right because
the the lab that i was in
was actually a lab of
effectively refugees from the rest of
the biology department these are people
who understood the power of selection
and so you know the funny thing is i
graduated having come from the the um
the entomology lab
i'm not an entomologist i studied bats
and most of the people in that lab under
dick alexander didn't study bugs
they studied dolphins and birds and
every other thing right
and the reason was that that was the
place where people who understood the
power of selection had gathered because
it wasn't all that hospitable anywhere
else in the department right the
ecologists by and large didn't get it
right the the cellular molecular people
didn't get it
and so the point is look
you don't you believe
in the evolutionary story
in the textbook which is a feeble
cartoon compared to the real thing right
the idea that you think you know
anything about the virus that you've
created when what you've really done is
put something on the foothill of some
mountain range you don't know anything
about and what you do know is that it's
got a program for climbing right it's
going to become something it's not under
your control the question is what niche
did you just bring it to
and
we can there's a perfectly good example
of this
hawaii is a tropical
uh landmass right it's a tropical
archipelago
you would expect high biological
diversity because tropical habitats tend
to have high biological diversity but it
doesn't because it's so remote right
it's remote and that means things don't
get to hawaii and so what's there are
things that were very good at crossing
extremely long inhospitable distances
right so it's a interesting habit lots
of unique things there but it's not high
diversity
you can take almost any mainland
creature there that finds it
climatically hospitable and the thing
will take off because you've solved the
hard problem of getting to hawaii by
taking it there on an airplane and now
it's a better competitor than all the
things that were adapted for getting to
a place like hawaii and persisting there
so the point is
we've introduced creatures we've
introduced you know mongoose for example
you can't get rid of them right what
you've just done is solved an
evolutionary problem that evolution
couldn't solve
and then you've let evolution take it
from there and this is a recipe for
disaster the idea that you're going to
create something in a lab and think that
you're its master come on
this is natural selection it built you
right this is the most powerful process
for you know upending plans that could
conceivably exist and you're just
playing with fire and what's more you're
not playing with fire in the way that
people used to play with firework they
would blow themselves up
you're talking about the whole world
somebody made an error in fact in this
case people were wise enough to see it
coming and they tried to ban this
research and anthony fauci decided to
override them
right
that error anthony fauci overriding a
gain of function
research ban very likely resulted
in a particular viral particle escaping
off a particular lab bench into a
particular human being and then covet 19
right that is the the capacity of
selection to take a tiny error right
literally a microscopic error and turn
it into a global catastrophe that's the
power of the process you're [ __ ] with
and if you don't respect it
you know we're going to be facing this
again and again because our power is
only
growing with respect to starting these
things to setting them in motion
and you know oh it's such a terrible
terrible failure of wisdom
i completely agree so yeah rant on
[Music]